what's up nerd oh hey Lamar so let's
talk about the first three weeks oh yeah
sure I mean we're really happy with how
the first three weeks have gone and
you're playing great yeah I know
hey me what I thought you didn't want to
negotiate during the season why are you
questioning me right now I'm doing you a
favor how so I'm giving you a chance to
pay me before I continue torching the
league and before I inevitably win MVP
now I suggest you take advantage of this
opportunity unless you want to end up
like the Yankees did with Aaron judge
yeah we're screwed yeah you are plus if
I keep throwing a Mark Andrews like this
you're gonna have to pay him like 20 mil
a year too so yeah why don't you ever
throw to your actual wide receivers my
what never mind all right we'll pay you
what do you want at least 250 million
fully guaranteed we can't do that all
right fine
touchdown what was that I just threw
another touchdown each one raises my
price by 10 million we're not even
playing a game right now I know that's
just how good I am we're screwed yeah
you are